[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compath 10 vous présente double jeu
l'émission de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
il
les
[Musique]
ce soir
le double jeu retrouvé de la part de
charles pour sa petite femme diana paul
anka
après lady di monsieur dit dit khaled
tube de l'été
plus les infos intox de philippe guérin
les bonnes bourde laurent baffie les
platines d'ordre philippe corti et en
invité vedette frédéric mitterrand et
robert de niro
et non pas bons soirs comme ça ça fait
ça fait folle ça c'est pas bien bonsoir
bonsoir
mais non c'est vous de guerre bonsoir
ils n'ont pas pas une petite voix de
fausset ya peu viril quand même bonsoir
bonsoir
non vous me dire bonjour bonjour bonsoir
cette émission est stupide
ce soir la zone ibérique
je peux me permettre c'est pas très bon
quand même ça va t-on à un chrétien
comme ça on fait mieux
on dit par exemple son père vous a fait
danser et pendant des années sa mère
vous a fait chanter pendant des années
tout l'effet d'hollywood se sont
penchées sur son berceau
y aller ce soir dans notre cas paraît
approcher la money money voici la zam
minnelli
non ça va pas qu'est ce que ce nom mais
j'en parlerai j'ai un copain qui avait
faire 3 limoges ça devrait marcher et
engageront quand on a des stars de ce
calibre dans une émission pareille ce
qui est quand même vraiment un cadeau on
est en fait un effort on fait au fait
quand même mieux
on dit par exemple vous auriez voulu le
suivre dans son équipée sauvage en
revenant du mans vous auriez aimé le
suivre quand il marchait sur les quais
vous auriez aimé le suivre quand il
dansait le dernier tango à paris ce
n'était pas avec vous vous auriez aimé
le suivre pour qu'il vous protège comme
un parent et bien voilà il est là pour
vous ce soir l'unique le seul mâle
mandat
ce soir non ça va mal en chaleur enfin
s'agissant du type oui à te préparer tes
que je veux quelqu'un préparer pour toi
tu vas neveu terry de la télévision
voici celui qui laisse les récompenses à
terre pour mieux monter aussi elle y
célébrer les étoiles frédéric mitterrand
bonsoir
[Musique]
bonsoir l'huma bichat je regarde pas
beaucoup la téloche moi mais j'ai
entendu dire que tu travailles et ça va
être bien là bas faire plein de meuf un
pari c'est pas ton genre mais quand même
tu connais du monde là bas pour me faire
entrer je connais quelques personnes
mais à huy d'une williams amf
elle a gagné là elle a gagné la sacrée
soirée elle a mis la date de sa c'est
pas la naissance de cinq ans mère des
trucs comme ça et là gagner la qualié
500 balles tu le connais foucault tu les
aimes bien faut qu une fois je les ai
vus alors qu'il sortait de son avion à
marseille et il avait l'air tellement
content de rentrer dans sa ville que je
les je me suis dit voilà ça c'est un
type c'est un type qui est sympathique
communiqué qui aime la vie
voilà c'est tout il passe quelques fois
à star 92 la star drucker tu le connais
de rigueur car j'adore dans lequel
j'adore c'est un type c'est leur art
type c'est l'unique même qui quand on se
plante vous téléphone le lendemain pour
vous dire c'est pas grave tu passeras à
travers cette année encore actes m
dunkerque m
je parie que tu aimes sébastien aussi
c'est ne peut pas dire du mal de ce type
là parce que s'ils sont là où ils sont
on peut ton peuple on peut on peut dire
qu'on n'est pas comme eux et qu'on veut
pas de ce système là et qu'on veut pas
faire les mêmes choses ça c'est ça c'est
un point mais c'est difficile de dire du
mal de ce qu'ils ont tous quelque chose
est certaine tout le monde quoi en fait
un peut-être genre comme tout le monde
t'aime personnes en fait mais tu dis que
tu aimes tout le monde dames par exemple
sabatier chez surcôte il est beau c'est
un patrick quintal m sabatier moi je
laime bien sont une relation
curieuse parce qu'on vive absolument pas
du tout dans le même monde et
pourtant il il ya toujours beaucoup de
beaucoup d'attention comme ça et le
résultat ça fait une relation assez
longue et qui marche plutôt bien
elle était un mec bizarre toi un peu
d'histoire comme ça un peu pervers les
émissions comme ça un peu au-dessous de
la ceinture thème bien comme ça on a des
genres de chavannes ça me prend à st
j'ai fait une fois son émission j'en
suis parti plutôt bien tiré et je dois
dire que que c'était amusant j'ai pas
regretter un qui s'emballe bien gelée
vue là il est les os 7 d'or now césar
était toujours avec des belles femmes
est tous un peu pas ton genre quoi un
montiel n'a que 7 ans bernard montiel
adorable et l'autre la paix n'était pas
là non
ppda là c'est un pote à toi aussi ppda
c'est quand même mon frère c'est à dire
que j'ai un peu avec ppda la même
relation que j'ai avec michel drucker
adesanya une meuf
si je pouvais l'amener à villetaneuse ça
déconcentre est là avec à démonter moi
car ça va la dance et d'un kevin claire
chazal est divine
il ya des mecs là comme ça ils m'ont dit
à qui tu avais un petit béguin la cour
guillaume durand d'un temps les mecs
comme ça allait solide light ont peur de
rien c'est entré cueillir un jeu
l'adorent guillaume durand alors là si
on regarde l'émission je les adore
guillaume durand il est incroyablement
sexy quand on est en contact avec lui
moi il ya ma copine regarde la télé tous
les dimanches
moi c'est pas vraiment mon truc mais
pense à une laisse tranquille alors en
garde jacques martin qui vient de là que
martin mais aussi jacques martin 7 à la
télévision l'équivalent des monstres
sacrés du cinéma
les grands rôles français les haribo
rouler simone signoret j'aimerais bien
[ __ ] j'aimerais vraiment bien munich et
j'aimerais bien de coincer un soir aux
folies bergères et tac ont bien réagi st
j'ai deux copains j'en ai un qui
convolait mon vieux j'aimerais bien
[ __ ] à pourvoir
qui dit toujours il allume toujours tout
le monde sait à ce mec là mais je peux
pas l'encadrer qu'ils aimeraient bien
voir comment il est quand il fait
comment il s'appelle déjà
hérisson
ensemble là ensemble alors harrison
thierry ardisson à ce que je peux
vraiment pas le sac et je trouve
vulgaire méchant agressif
ok physiquement je trouve assez attirant
quand même
[Musique]
or bonsoir on recommence bonsoir dix
mois alors ceux où ce bout là que tu
viens de faire du gentil avec tout le
monde au fonds tu aimes que toi même et
tu pourquoi fais-tu mine d'être gentil
avec tout le monde connaît un homme est
en fait je suis assez gentil quand même
et j'ai beaucoup de la télévision ces
meurtriers
quand on dit quelque chose de méchant
sur quelqu'un c'est terrible ce qui
appâte vraiment de droit de réponse et
on peut faire un mâle l'épouvantable aux
gens c'est c'est trop c'est ses employés
une bombe atomique en face d'une fronde
donc c'est pas la peine tu publies le
tome 3 c'est notre destin des toits a
fait un peu de promo voilà donc tu es
sur la gravité dans toutes les émissions
après ce que tu vois je veux faire des
émissions
je tiens beaucoup à ses livres je suis
donné beaucoup de mal pour les pour les
pour les soigner comme ça et je ne veux
ne faire que des émissions où j'ai
l'impression que de l'est que les gens
qui les qui me reçoivent les auront
suffi on va continuer le ouzou mais
cette fois non plus avec des gens qui
font des émissions de télévision avec
les héros de son livre raconte juan
carlos par exemple je dirais quoi
juan carlos se tiraient une chose c'est
que l'on peut être un type très bien en
mentant pendant longtemps
c'est ce qu'il a fait parce qu'il a
menti il a menti à son père il a menti à
son père adoptif qui était le dictateur
franco
il s'est sans doute même entier lui même
en se disant je vais y arriver mais je
sais pas comment et puis finalement tout
ça c'était pour la bonne cause et il a
très bien réussi
et tout ça ça fait quelqu'un qui est
très profondément humain en fait et pour
une situation difficile des gens humains
je crois pas beaucoup à l'intelligence
en politique on a des gens intelligents
il y en a partout des gens humains il y
en a beaucoup
il ya eu des tas d'hommes politiques en
france qui étaient très intelligents
mais il n'était pas n'hésitez pas humain
où il n'avait pas l'humanité qui
convenait à c'était à l'époque avec
élise était et le résultat c'était
souvent désastreux brigitte bardot c'est
toujours un peu agaçant tout le monde
d'y regarder à abroger de bardos riyad
est ce qu'elle est devenue
brigitte bardot les petites bêtes etc
c'est plus compliqué en tout cas
brigitte bardot a inventé des choses
très importantes qui ont été ensuite
complètement recyclés et récupérés par
mai 68 mais en fait la vie près de la
nature de une autre approche des
rapports humains entre les gens le refus
de la carrière à tout prix tout ça elle
a été là elle a été la première elle ne
le dira pas mais quand aller quand c'est
celle rêve
on en rencontre quelques fois des gens
qui ont tout et dont on n'est pas jaloux
parce qu'il se comporte tellement bien
avec tout ce dont il dispose
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont tout et
qui font tout mal et puis il ya quelques
personnes qui ont tout et qui font aussi
tout bien et c'était indiquant qu' eva
peron et bien cette femme de la rue avec
carlos gardel qui avait la musique aussi
les airs cette femme a apporté de
l'histoire on a été là le premier moment
d'histoire alors évidemment ce n'est pas
une histoire très très reluisant c'est
une histoire qui vient un peu des
bas-fonds et tout ça mais c'est une
vraie histoire c'est un vrai modèle
simple un vrai truc que les argentins
honte à eux est une chose qui est
incroyable avec eva peron cette pensée
que s'il était encore vivante elle
aurait 70 ans c'est à dire qu elle
serait là encore là serait sans doute
devenue féministe elle aurait fait deux
come back en public
c'est incroyable de penser les charts
chaplin parce que tu prends bien soin de
chelsea n'ont pas de charlieu cette
écharpe
charles chaplin pas ce que c'était
c'était comme picasso comme stravinsky
c'était des gens comme ça planétaire ils
n'étaient pas paraît-il très sympathique
mais je sais pas si picasso puisqu'elle
souhaitait un monstre et je suis pas sûr
que stravinsky était très sympathique
non plus mais en tout cas ils avaient là
il avait le souffle du siècle il avait
le souffle de tout traversé de tout voir
et lui il a tout traversé et tout vu un
gamin qui se parlent se cassent les
pieds il a il a tout traversé et tout vu
avec une force inconnue
alors quand on quand on lit le livre on
a l'impression d'entendre ta voix ouais
un peu un peu lever et parce que je
parle finalement d'une manière
totalement naturelle
les gens me reconnaissent ils c'est
malheureusement c'est naturel tdi déjà
quand j'étais en classe quand je parlais
il y avait toute la classe qui est parlé
après que ça commençait à me tienne tu
t'en es rendu compte très vite alors de
l'importance de ta voix dans ton service
n'obtenez pas savoir connais pas savoir
n'a pas l'habitude des voix je te dire
que la première fois où je me suis
entendu j'étais affolée et après je me
suis résigné quand même je me suis
habitué
tu écris comment j'écris dans le
désordre debout avec cinq personnes dans
la pièce away est comme ça que j'écris
bien
ah bon et le téléphone qui sonne avec l
agitation et une heure de retard sur le
moment où je vais rendre le tablier
c'est très bien documenté ouais y'a pas
de révélations extraordinaires en avance
c'est toujours pareil je suis trop
gentil j'aime pas le dire je charge les
méchants et j'ai fait tout passer sur
des méchants à l'âge les dix mois ses
comparses c'est parce que tu attends tu
dis moi frédéric gil à travers les
questions non pas du tout ça fait parce
que tu n'arrives pas à t'aimer que tu
adores autant les stars non c'est je me
prends pour elle
ce qui est un truc plus compliqué mais
en fait qui est à la base du système
destin c'est un marche parce que les
gens se prennent pour elle un choix sans
frais 1 sur tout ce qui fonctionne et ce
qui fonctionne par affectif parler de
gens viennent par voilà quand tu peux
pas non parce que je peux pas faire 1
étoile sur clerc eva braun et elle lui
tendit sa tasse de thé dans le bunker en
flammes il la regarda il pense là à mon
amour séminaire était avec nous et que
l'apocalypse nous suivent
non ça je dis pas non je peux pas j'ai
fait une fois en rigolant et puis les
mots se sont bloquées j'ai rêvé plus est
ce que tu feras ton oncle certainement
un jour certainement mais et je dire ça
sera quelque chose qui sera tellement
pas forcément important pour les gens et
qui sera tellement important pour moi
que j'attends encore un peu le faire et
parce que j'essaierai de faire vraiment
bien et puis je suis tellement surpris
de gens je vois tellement d'image de lui
et j'en ai eu notre personnel qui est
encore tellement différentes que je
voudrais arriver a raconté cette image
personnelle et pour celles là peut-être
qu'il faut que les autres ça pèse un peu
c'est un peu des monuments aux morts
oui j'adore les cimetières regarde la
grande guerre et la guerre de 39-45 ont
laissé derrière elles un grand nombre de
victimes et chaque village a son
monument aux morts mais la france
n'avait pas encore on se demande bien
pourquoi de monument dédié à la mémoire
des femmes mortes à la guerre depuis
novembre dernier
l'oubli est réparé richesse et un petit
village du territoire de belfort a érigé
le premier monument aux morts tu de
l'histoire de notre pays
il a vu le jour grâce à l'obstination du
général bataille un ancien de l'armée du
maréchal de lattre
c'est une dame qui s'appelle madame
bareigts qui est aujourd'hui décédé
depuis trois mois qui est venu pour me
demander de construire un monument pour
rendre hommage aux femmes qui avaient
combattu pendant la guerre et en
particulier aux ambulancière
du 25ème bataillon médical qu'il l'avait
rencontrée donc adel au moment de la
libération depuis le débarquement nous
notre unité poursuivaient toujours la
19e armée allemande que nous avons
poursuivi jusqu'au fond de l'allemagne
ce secteur a été particulièrement
meurtrier
le médecin capitaine chainel a été tué
madame lefort cook est grièvement blessé
et trois de mes camarades blessés
également 156 associations d'anciens
combattants 24 communes et conseils
généraux 19 comité du souvenir français
ont financé ce monument aux morts où
paradoxalement ne figure qu'un seul nom
de femme sa réalisation a été confiée à
roger petit un ancien para sculpteur
amateur et je lui ai dit voilà je
voudrais la pierre blanche pour rappeler
la pureté des ambulancières une pierre
rouge si possible pour rappeler la terre
de france sur laquelle les hommes sont
morts et pour laquelle il combattait est
très symbolique
et puis c'est un million 1 et lors des
gens du pays et qui est ont connu le
sacrifice de ces femmes qui ont connu
leur courage et qu'ils ont un bon jour
voulu leur rendre hommage
ce n'est que justice
le premier
alors qu'en france s de l'info os de
l'intox
frédéric mitterrand à l'oreille bien
simon petit à l'oreille à l'oreille
alors mesdames messieurs pendant que
liza minnelli et marlon brando
réfléchissent pendant que vous tapez sur
votre militaire qu'est-ce qu'on écoute
partie regardons ensemble écrit julie
clips des femmes caméléon
c'est une équipe partir c'est vraiment
rigueur écoute sans frais venant en
mission littéraire c'est quand même
assez bon et toi après la maréchal de
lattre comment est ce que tu te laisses
faire des choses pas non mais je savais
que je ne devrais pas tout en maintenant
son bain alors il vaut mieux qu'on
écoute quelque chose d'encore plus frais
paul anka diana
[Musique]
je te vois tu sais
grâce aux vols en pleine
[Musique]
alors
enfin voilà
à
mais comme attaquant guillaume hamon
il y a
car je suis
à
parent
ah non là
il y a
[Applaudissements]
en
la table
[Musique]
kaka
wen devant nous
m
en résumé m
la paille
[Musique]
en france s de l'info est de l'intox
visa à toi de jouer
je pense que c'est de l'info de l'info
oui la faux lui m'a dit de la taxe et un
frédéric mais moi je voudrais bien que
ce soit de l'info un oui bon mais c'est
bien fait d'ailleurs enfin il ya des
vrais infirmières il ya une vraie marée
châble c'est un vrai ardisson qui a fait
l'émission de 1 mais elle s'est quand
même de l'intense moi je serais plutôt
de l'avis de frédéric pour moi c'est de
l'intox pour toi c'est bien le montage
est très bien fait mais il me semble que
il ya quelque chose qui va pas on voit
pas le monument mais c'est être un piège
on va écouter l'expert si les gars
arrivées comptant les minions il est
mignon et thierry avant que se donne la
réponse serait de demander quelque chose
tu connais la tunisie non il va pas
c'est dommage parce que tu pourrais
peut-être un petit peu parce que dans
les coulisses on se disait et toute
l'équipe que ça serait bien si fredo
présenté à la rentrée il veut plus je te
rassure tout de suite il veut plus bon
d'accord non plus il s'est planté parce
que c'était de l'info
[Applaudissements]
31 saga sans se tromper et oui c'est de
l'info petit veinard vous venez
d'admirer une fois de plus l'expression
au travers de ce reportage du génie
français qui quand il crée le premier
monument aux morts tu es inscrit
plusieurs dizaines de noms d'hommes et
un seul nom de femme alors deux
solutions à cette énigme soit la guerre
de 39-45 n'a fait qu'une seule victime
de sexe féminin soit à la france a
encore du mal à retrouver sa mémoire au
sujet de cette triste période
non il ya une troisième possibilité oui
avait peut-être un bataillon de
travestis voilà mais ça on peut pas dire
ça
la porte non pas si un zéro pour
l'alcool et repenti
j'ai perdu c'est pas la première fois
dis moi je vais le perdre on va voir tu
as dit à ma naissance c'est mon père qui
a été obligé de me ramener à la vie
c'est très privé tout ça ouais et huard
ajouté d'ailleurs après j'ai été obligé
de me ramener plusieurs fois moi même à
la vie mais la première fois fin quand
tu es né son père l'a ramené à la vie ça
s'est passé comme on t'a raconté ça
souvent non chez toi non on va pas
raconter ça souvent parce que j'ai pas
des parents du genre fronty j'hérite
était foutue repas sauver non non c'est
pas le genre créanciers mais peut-être
c'est à cause de ça doit peut-être des
neurones qui n'ont pas été aussi donnés
il c'était ma question est ce que tu
crois que tu en voilà
je pense qu'il ya dû y avoir un truc qui
a manqué qui manquent encore ouais mais
je préfère quil mai
errani mais que rien du tout malgré tout
et en tout cas je sais qu'il a fait et
c'est lui qui a fait ça mon père m'a
donné la vie mais ma mère aussi
d'ailleurs mais a faim et nous voulons
redonner qu'ils ont l'un et l'autre un
an que le président un autre général oui
et on perd il faisait quoi nos pères ils
faisaient des affaires il faisait très
bien et en fait il était il est l'aîné
de la famille
en fait c'est mieux de la famille qui
les a tous élevés à fait tes parents
divorcés un moment même et un monument
serré et tu as dit c'est peut-être là
aussi une des sources de tes angoisses
cela dit je suis quelqu'un à qui il
manquera toujours quelque chose à dire
que en supporte mal quand on est enfant
que le monde s'écroule quand les parents
c'est pas céder le monde s'écroule alors
bon après en se réorganisant se réadapte
mais je sais pas moi en tout cas ça m'a
ça m'a sans doute pour marquer mais
j'aurais été plus marquée si il s'était
disputé rester ensemble
est ce que tu crois que tu as
fascination pour les couples royaux
vient dé du monde et rémy c'est l'idée
de quelque chose qui finit pas mais ton
attirance pour la monarchie
c'est ton côté midinette surtout non je
ne crois pas non plus à côté au début ça
a commencé dans un peu pour une
provocation parce que j'en avais marre
d'être
comme ça catalogué le 9e tout ça et puis
et puis je me suis vraiment intéressé et
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
pas que des imbéciles ou des des
névrosés qui s'y intéresser alors ça m'a
un peu rassurée mais au plan politique
est-ce que tu serais d'accord pour qu'on
fasse un référendum en france pour
demander aux gens non
shiva la monarchie ou la république ne
seraient pas d'accord parce qu'on voit
pas ce que parce que les gens n'ont pas
besoin parce que c'est un jeu n'ont plus
besoin ils ont une
en france c'est des institutions de
gaulle a fait des institutions très bon
est parfaite
ou parce qu'elle réconcilie et on va pas
faire un cours de droit constitutionnel
mais elle réconcilie toutes les
tendances françaises elles sont les
institutions de la monarchie est un roi
élu pour sept ans + 7 ans ça fait 14 ans
c'est le temps à rennes où ces
interminables
c'est bonapartiste parce qu'il parle
directement au peuple
et puis c'est la république parce que
parce que c'est un président de la
république
ces institutions idéal d'ailleurs lui
vous l'aurez voulu avoir une monarchie
mais puis finalement il s'est dit que
c'était pas possible il ya pensé semble
t on dit un peu trop qu'il ya pensé à
mon avis il n'ya pas pensé énormément
des lettres quand même
il ya pensé dis moi c'est quand même pas
étrange que le voeu du présent à public
soit royalistes non un nom parce que
toute façon si c'était une monarchie je
serai prêt du trône c'était et des
défauts ne veut de françois mitterrand
franchement non je crois pas non je
pense que simplement c'est un
multiplicateur c'est un multiplicateur
davantage de ces un multiplicateur
d'ennui c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens
qui deviennent plus aimable il y en a
d'autres qui deviennent moins aimables
mais si les gens deviennent plus aimable
pour ça au moins aimables pour ça de
toute façon il se trompe ça n'a aucun
intérêt donc c'est pas des gens en fait
avec qui j'ai tellement envie d'être
donc finalement ça n'a aucune importance
y en a qui viennent plus finir aussi
parce que tu disais je sais plus où que
des gens finalement comme ils bossent
avec toi ils disent pour rien lui
arriver à lui donc il a tort le milieu
de son cher c'est le directeur ça
s'était toujours débit bref c'était tout
au début mais ça a beaucoup changé
ouais c'est un nom difficile à porter
aujourd'hui mitterrand c'est à dire
qu'il ya des moments où je me dis si ça
se termine mal je vais être obligé de
m'exiler à la havane viande ça ça va
être dur comme les enfants allende
j'ai pas vu donc j'aurai ça se termine
tranquille 1 mais j'aurai ça se termine
bien aussi parce que j'ai pas envie non
plus de de traîner derrière moi pendant
les années qui me reste à vivre toutes
les casseroles que tonton râler c'est
vraiment je trouve ça se termine bien
à part ça a pas ça regarde je vivrai
quand même très bien tu vois tout le
monde le sait et aime neveu de françois
mitterrand
ça c'est parce qu'il ya une transition
on reconnaît le professionnel de la
professionnelle
elle prend la fuite
comment s'appelle l'oncle de frédéric
mitterrand l'oncle je ne sais pas le nom
d'amy terran forcément mais son don
mitterrand allez-y c'est tout mitterrand
sur prénom je ne sais pas l'oncle de
frédéric mitterrand madame l'oncle de
frédéric mitterrand s'il ya un piège
autre histoire mais je n'y touche pas
messier comment s'appelle longue de
frédéric mitterrand et b selon fo
frédéric mitterrand choco qui sert
jamais non le jeune acteur s'est pas
alors on dit quoi je vous dis je
je disais je suis je serai dans tête
vous répondre françois mitterrand mais
je suis sûr que c'est pas ça fait quoi
je ne sais pas mais j'y vais c'est très
facile
ciao et e
on s'appelle françois mettant c'est le
président de la république vous mêlez de
l'ombre des sémites est là mais elle
sait pas qui a et vétérans
[Applaudissements]
tu m'en veux pas mais prévu à 12 ans tu
as été choisi oui barjots fait pour
retourner dans fortunat avec bourvil et
michèle morgan
kevin dans l'est aussi comment s'est
passée cette audition l'audition j'y
suis allé tout seul donc comme tous les
autres enfants y aller avec leur maman
ils ont été un peu surpris de voir un
gosse arrivé tout seul comme ça je
m'étais cassé le bras fin j'étais pas en
forme donc je devais avoir un côté
pleurnichard émouvant 1 et ça allait
bien
et puis après j'ai fait tous les essais
et sans rien dire à mes parents n'y a
personne alors c'était un peu mystérieux
sept enfants et en plus je leur avais
même pas dit mon nom
donc ce n'était pas pas prévu c'était
aussi la timidité qui joue elle est
comme ça et donc ça leur a plu
et finalement ils m'ont pris et 12 ans
plus tard à 24 ans tue c'est en lisant
une petite annonce que tu vas trouver le
cinéma olympique avant voilà avant oui
mais tu avais envie de diriger des
cinémas ils sont en voyant la petite
annonce que tu te dis pourquoi y'a une
chose c'est quand on met un enfant dans
le cinéma ça le reste de sa vie quoi
je pense que déjà un jour j'avais fait
une émission sur les enfants qui ont
fait du cinéma et c'était incroyable
s'apercevoir qu'ils étaient tous restés
dans une profession
après il n'avait jamais réussi à s'en
défaire et moi c'était mon cas j'ai fait
des études et tout ça et puis je me suis
dit j'aimerais montrer des films et puis
j'ai fait ça pendant 15 ans ce qu'ils
vont même très long trop long
tu t'es retrouvé 4 millions d'êtres oui
peut-être un peu plus même beaucoup
quand même
j'en ai payé beaucoup c'était mal géré
non c'était pas gérer ses terres
pas mal gérée s'était pas gérer ces de
lapsus non c'était géré en fait
simplement j'ai un côté obstiné donc je
me suis obstinée et alors ça perdait de
l'argent mais jamais jamais assez pour
ça fasse faillite et à chaque fois il y
avait un truc qui faisait ça remarche
est un petit peu donc je m'enfonçais de
lentement et puis je m'accrochais est
alors j'aurais dû m'arrêter après sept
ou huit ans ben j'ai tenu 15 ans comme
ça évidemment à l'arrivée au terminus la
facture a été salée qui a le plus
contribué à un flou et de le dette de
l'olympique c'est tf1 ou un peu de ces
c'est ce que j'ai fait à côté c'est les
pubs c'est l'hôtel ça opel opel m'a fait
beaucoup de bien à peu de dire que la
corsa accords s'inscrivent pour la corse
à la corse à la cadette
je les prends tout en 82 tu venais de
faire lettres d'amour de semaine
et puis c'était pas très bien cette
époque là non mais le film était bien
bénin va bien dans le film
ouais tu termines affaire la télévision
we can alioui alors ça c'est bizarre oui
ben ça y est tu croyais que ça va être
soigné
ça m'a soigné comme un ça m'a fait
beaucoup de bien ça m'a donné une
capacité comme ça de résistance que je
ne vais pas avoir tu as dis quand même
dans télérama en 1990 tu as dit à la
télévision j'ai montré ce qu'il y avait
de bien chez les gens de la télévision
ne m'a pas aidé à trouver ce qui est
bien en moi quand même j'ai dit ça ouais
j'ai dit ça oui tu peux dire c'est le
journaliste qui s'est trompé le fonds de
l'ina
non non maintenant parce que j'ai salle
télérama mais j'arrive dans un moment
comme ça mais d'ailleurs c'est vrai en
fait
en fait la télévision ne m'a ne m'a pas
vraiment apporté de de sécurité mental
aucune aucune
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je n'en
fais plus parce que finalement elle ne
m'a pas
rassurée je n'en fais plus comme j'en
faisais avant et peut-être que je n'en
ferais plus du tout ça ne me manque pas
c'est très bizarre
ces deux noms ça manque pas ce qui me
manque pas du tout il ya d'abord une
première chose c'est la notoriété la
notoriété c'est formidable mais c'est un
mauvais truc c'est un truc qui vous
sépare de ce que ce qu'on voudrait que
ce qui est important
et moi je commençais à avoir une
relation malsaine avec la notoriété
c'est à dire je commençais à être
vraiment content d'être connu et c'est
mauvais ça à cause de ça on ne fait pas
de longs métrages on n'écrit pas de
livres ont fait pas les choses
importantes et donc j'ai commencé à me
méfier de ça beaucoup et je le dis
vraiment en connaissance de cause parce
que en même temps la notoriété c'est
très agréable
c'est comme une drogue c est finalement
je me suis aperçu que tout mon rapport
avec la télévision fonctionner comme un
rapport de drogue c'est à dire que
c'était ce qui importe et c'était dedans
faire tout le temps tout le temps est
plus de savoir ce que j'allais en faire
or ce qui est important c'est de savoir
ce qu'on va faire des choses et puis je
m'apercevais aussi que mes relations
avec les gens devenaient des relations
télévisuelle je regardais les gens en me
disant est ce qu'on va pouvoir enfin ses
bons clients certains tout en relation à
la vie devenait complètement fausses et
ça et ça il faut refuser ça complètement
ton pire moment à la télé c'était quoi
pire moment et puis on mangera que
c'était le cinéma européen en direct ah
oui c'est à des champs-elysées etc
rien n'a marché où je m'étais donné
beaucoup de mal pour faire un truc était
bien et ou alors je l' ai senti dès le
début derrière le rideau s'est ouvert et
avant même et enfin j'ai senti que ça
marcherait pas et il y avait sept salles
classées comme ça et je me suis ennuyé à
mourir et j'avais j'ai vraiment été à
deux ou trois moments sur le point de
partir c'est à dire demi heure mais
qu'est ce que je voulais sans ces
sensations alors un peu comme moi
maintenant
et encore là aujourd'hui dix mois le set
de haut alors quand tu l'as mis à terre
là en disant que tu veux mais tu es là
où était le service public ce n'était
pas prémédité sais rien pourquoi c'est
un beau geste n'était pas prémédité
c'est venu comme ça en fait c'est lui
parce que le programme delà de cette
soirée-là 17 d'or était vraiment
insupportable il y avait que des enfants
qui chantonnait et qui faisait des
cabrioles et tous arrêtés c'était tf1 à
son pire même en a la larme à
l'abêtissement est épouvantable est il
sauvé quand même je la télévision avait
plein de problèmes ce soir là et tous
les gens d'y trouver ça très bien disait
rien dit et moi je suis content et vous
semblez mec viré avec la marque de la
semaine sur un portail non je suis
rapide tout ça mais bon il y avait une
sorte de de mensonges quand même
incroyable
alors voilà c'est comme ça on n'a jamais
retrouvé son corps non mais c'est bien
son match de la revanche dans l'air de
rien alors j'ai un agent regard des gens
et on sait pas arrivé depuis la non non
non il émission genre surprise c'est pas
tu as dit qui aurait pu penser à
l'arrivée des khmers rouges en voyant
débarquer française bouygues
oui c'est vrai je pense que oui gaffet
la télévision ce que les khmers rouges
au cambodge
oui malheureusement je sais pas cian
aucun la vérité c'est que je m'en fous
enfin c'est la preuve que tu t'en fous
c'est qu'un jour chez tf1
ils t'ont vu en tutu à bordeaux oui
c'est ça la france il a choqué face à la
menace était au dessus parce que
justement les gens en avaient marre j'en
avais un peu marre et j'aurais pu faire
piller encore simplement j'ai toujours
peur que ma mère regarde la télévision
ma grand mère et tout ça et comme je
suis l'une des brouilles mal que
j'arrive une ou deux fois j'ai été
prévenue j'allais dire regardez pas la
télé mais on samedi soir à damas se sont
précipités de leurs copines de tout ça
et après pendant quinze jours tout le
monde à fonctionner aux tranquillisants
donc je ne fais plus ça
j'étais bien là ça va là là je suis peu
se fichent genre ça j'ai trouvé ça très
sage saison fait que la tv de lui très
conformiste quand même oui la télé
devenue très conformiste mais moi je dis
c'est marrant parce que moi je le
vaudois
ouais troisième jeu pleut qu'on en
finisse une bonne fois pour toutes
ailleurs peut-être tendancieux
c'est pas ton char j'essaie d'arrêter à
ce rebond
pour vous éclater les ultimes la preuve
que non parce que la chambre de députés
plein d'histoires à cause de ça et on
s'est fait allumer par le monde comme il
ya 20 ans n'ait pas remarqué les
journalistes ils sont complètement fous
avec la télé ou souvenu d'avoir les gens
et c'est un très au sérieux alors sans
argent mat et l'espagne au sérieux les
journalistes est normalement une vision
ma tête il parce qu'ils passent pas les
portos ils sont
il y a jamais sanction parce que
finalement quand on fait des bêtises de
la télévision on est viré mon cher dans
une scène et war les sanctions quand
même bon journaliste jamais partir
n'importe quoi ils peuvent mentir le
vrai conte et n'importe quoi sont jamais
sanctionnés jamais ça marche toujours
et ils ont alors une espèce d'obsession
la télévision ici on croirait qu'ils
n'ont rien d'autre à faire que la
regarder du matin jusqu'au soir et donné
les jugements et dire ceci est dire cela
moi je suis très
je suis très
est frappée de voir comment comment ils
se comportent ils ont un comportement
infantile avec le temps tu vas voir un
sujet de ma fille alors oui je préfère
beaucoup parler ah oui non mais quand
même quelque chose sur la télé confort
missoup avait pas confirmé moi qui suis
un type qui aime les choses soft et
j'adore regarder à la télévision des
émissions rude
je considère que tournée mission
séduction assez rude on y dit des choses
on y fait des choses pas faire
j'aime pas par contre tout ce qui est
racheté vie tout ça change vraiment
racheter vis ça c'était vraiment dégueu
l'intérieur voir les pauvres
pourquoi une femme qui dit qu'elle a
tout perdu et tout ça mais cela ils
n'ont pas de problème se trouve ça
épouvantable
par contre être ici être être cinq ans
comme ça c'est bien
je soutiens alors oui je vous ferai une
lettre les murs jeu animal laurent
baffie de m'afficher
[Musique]
le coût de la super quoi j'arrive pas
rien
soignez vous le cul quand même parce que
je retiens la nuit on fait quoi et
d'affaires au hip hop il un coup de main
je me suis fait mal et je n'arrive pas
pendant ce temps là il pense pas un
instant qui fait ça
france pas mal il marque pas le des prix
gémeaux qui pensait avoir ya ce qui fait
le gros ya tout y est tombé à l'asim ce
n est pas une
une fois ça on juil protestant monsieur
lambert je peux [ __ ]
vous avez quoi dans le paquet là c'est
du chocolat oui ah ben je vais manger un
bout d'un moment donné j'ai un petit
cousin moi j'ai besoin de lui ses amis
monsieur moix est adressé pour un enfant
et adolescent poule
je resterai gosse - donnez moi vous tu
vois pas question de déranger la haute
c'est pour un enfant la mesquinerie des
gens at il ajouté tiens tu veux me fila
comme un jeu super tendwa j'en ris pas
tu changeras rotman vécu juste mon mieux
mais qui arrive pas
des millions de francs dans ma poche la
visite pourtant sont allés ligne droite
a des couilles dans le son à laizy ça me
démange à les y aider moi c'est ma poche
je prenais à les hydrater juste un peu
d'écrits dans le fond à l'e10 que vider
les morpions et ça démange depuis ce
matin non mais écoutez vous êtes fous là
si mal c'est pas bien soulagés voit
servir de prête nom finalement je
préfère l'autre c'est-à-dire l'hôtel a
plus de gueule loyer celle là c'est pas
un mot nieuws et remettez d'autres
formes était celle là celle là l'est
alors là c'est l'épreuve et je peux à
l'armée mais c'est pas joli à regarder
c'est pas de la même couleur regarder
récusant pouces pour le stupa je n'ai
pas roulé qu'une caisse des blaireaux
s'il s'est pas jeudi à l'hôtel m'a roulé
avec a rappelé faisant cependant voiture
à la mienne elle est là bas d'autres
voies
michel
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce que tu fais
tu représentes antenne 2 en tunisie oui
je représente antennes dans tunisie
qu'est ce que tu fais c'est sale c'est
un plat cas où une sinécure non c'est
l'un ni l'un ni l'autre c'est qu ils ont
pensé que c'était un placard un peu
qu'ils ont sûrement pas nous ont envie
que tu reviens à je te le début est en
fait peut-être je sais vraiment je sais
dire il ya pire rien et celles servant
du travail comme un dieu a envoyé en or
buzz jours
oui mais on enrichit serait pas là où
j'y serai peut-être année mais il serait
pas resté mais pourquoi la tunisie
pourquoi pas l'algérie le maroc parce
que s'il faut quelqu'un comme toi en
tunisie il en fait aussi un en algérie
au maroc sans visage et en voyant les
baies il envisage d'envoyer à alger a
fait mouche et entre alger et tripoli
avaient été chaudement recommandé aux
frais de fonelle kadhafi lui mais il
hésite il trouve pas mal en fait a
choisi la tunisie parce que ta famille
une maison hammamet et que tu passes tes
vacances le bâtonnier un temps oui parce
qu'ils y vont est-ce que je connais en
fait parce que je connais le pays et
puis
mais c'est plus important as un pays
particulier la tunisie est un pays qui
est en tête quand même du maghreb est un
pays où on a uni a eu des gens qui ont
demandé à l'indépendance dans les années
quarante cinq étaient des gens
formidables et nouveau évidemment n'a
rien compris
mais si on leur avait accordé serait
tout changé ailleurs c'est un pays bien
me feriez bien tu vécu comment la guerre
du golfe
baba la guerre du golfe là bas je n'ai
vécu le jeune homme pense était très et
déchirant quand même parce que c'est
vrai que les médias français se
comporter se comporter d'une manière
folle et qu'on en entende et on voyait à
la télévision des choses
invraisemblables et la montée de
l'intégrisme tu devais comment là bas il
n'y a pas de monter materis
il ya eu il ya plus c'est l'intéressé
comme le pen c'est à dire que c'est
comme le pen ils arriveront jamais mais
par contre il ya un risque qu'ils
contaminent l'europe était fasciste ses
50 ans c'était été c'est pas loin pas
loin pas loin tu vas voir un truc pareil
en garde parce que tu me fais des
enchaînements non un vrai pro regarde
une ombre noire plane sur les jeux
olympiques de barcelone les pays
africains menace de boycotter les 22e
olympiades
si d'ici cet été ce guerrier noir
empaillés n'est pas retirée du musée de
banyoles une petite ville proche de
barcelone dans laquelle doivent se
dérouler les épreuves de ram à l'origine
de la polémique un médecin haïtien qui
découvrent par hasard le guerrier en
paille et noir exposés sont ni pudeur
dans ce musée d'histoire naturelle le
fait qu'un être humain en paille et se
trouve dans un musée qu'il soit blanc
noir chez nous envoie indien ma réaction
serait la même cela me semble aberrant
sanguinaire et humiliant les arguments
du docteur ar cela ne font pas
l'unanimité à banyoles un comité de
soutien aux guerriers secret badges à
l'appui la population est soutenu par
ses élus qui votent une délibération en
faveur du monde
un du guerrier on payet au musée exposé
ici depuis 1916 la dépouille naturalisé
est devenu en quelque sorte la mascotte
de la ville pendant que les catalans se
montrent irascibles partout dans le
monde les athlètes s'entraînent pour les
jeux de barcelone
certains d'entre eux sont écoeurés par
cette nouvelle péripétie
jeudi il ya encore eu trop de précédents
avec ta politique mélangés aux sports
nan moi je fais mon chez mon job entre
guillemets sur le terrain et j'essaie de
faire abstraction
par contre si je prends le parti de moi
même qui consiste à réfléchir aux
problèmes de ce monde
c'est vrai que l'on n'a pas droit de
laisser des choses comme ça traînait
effectivement il faut réagir
embarrassé par la controverse le comité
international olympique et désormais
quelque peu rassurés par les propos qu'a
tenus le ministre espagnol des
transports lors d'une visite à banyoles
qu'est ce qui me plaît je trouve quand
même que ce bonhomme en paille
ah oui il est très poussiéreux 75 ans
qui n'a pas bougé
est ce que vous pourriez pas le faire
nettoyer un peu moi je vous propose de
faire nettoyer à madre par le jeu des
occasions déterré en afrique par un
taxidermiste français vendus en espagne
le guerrier va peut être pouvoir grâce
aux jo en fin se reposer et bénéficier
d'une sépulture distincts
spiez de l'info est de l'intox federica
l'oreille ouais alors mesdames messieurs
quand vous demandez c'est de l'info ou
cissé l'intox pendant que lisa et marlon
réfléchissent qu'est-ce qu'on écoute
partie qu'est-ce qui est l'un des plus
que moi cela il a rien de tony chan
cetto voilà alors on ira tous les jours
et rôdent autour de la boutique 1 à part
le 12 mai alors va tenter avec le move
est bien le 12 mai rappelle 10 10
[Musique]
m
tout ça
[Musique]
jeudi
ep
[Musique]
je sais pas
je pars
est-ce que l'intox marraine à toi de
jouer pour moi c'est de l'intox de
l'intérieur lisa de l'intox aussi oui
oui toi tu me dis que c'était de l'intox
oui je penserai way sur ça horrible de
toute façon c'est pas très bon mais
peut-être que ce prix là il ya des gens
qui ont fait des abat jour pendant la
guerre ben oui bon on va écouter
l'expert philippe djian
sur le sujet je vais pas avoir le
triomphe très très haut parce que
c'était effectivement de l'info les
secours est pas changé thierry ouais
alors c'est 1-0 pour liza minnelli bien
je suis
m
alors lisez un tu prends ton petit
téléviseur tu regardes les cadeaux
philips qui défilent et tu me dises
celui que tu veux
ses new skies pollen la chaîne que
l'hôtel comprend un cd programme à un
ampli turballe générateur actionnaires
un double platine k7 autoreverse
barreaux
tu as gagné notre estime il faut être
sport il faut être sport la trace
autosport brodeur
quand j'étais petit oui tu voulais être
missionnaire chef démissionnaire tu
voulais être pape oui à la fin oui parce
que je me suis dit quand même très
toujours la fri des grandeurs mais nous
préférions si je voulais être finalement
j'ai fait ni l'un ni l'autre
j'attendais des bons chrétiens nom des
musulmans non non non je
la vérité si je ne crois pas en dieu je
ne crois pas que je crois pas je
regrette mais je crois pas à venir me
raconter ça d'accord
oui très glissant
et
[Musique]
donc frédéric tu ne le crois pas en dieu
je pense que dieu est peut-être mais en
tout cas certainement sous aucune des
formes que l'on nous a enseigné et et
moi j'ai sammour finalement ça me c'est
affreux à dire mais ça m'intéresse pas
est ce que ton fils mathieu est baptisée
wii il est baptisé parce que
j'attache beaucoup d'importance ah au
fait qu'un enfant
[Musique]
soit comme les autres et ça fait partie
de notre culture de notre de notre vie
et après il est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut donc il ya des gens qui tiennent le
raisonnement inverse
moi j'ai préféré celui-là du maquillage
maintenant il a 20 ans 21
on n'a jamais su si c'était ton ombre et
fils ou son fils de 20 ans est tout à
fait mon vrai fils c'était une c'est à
dire que c'est
il a vécu avec moi d'une manière un peu
compliqué à cause du désordre de la
jeunesse qui était ma jeunesse
en l'occurrence mais c'est mon vrai fils
et puis même si les témoins ont fils
adoptif il serait aussi membre et fils
toute façon je trouve terrible cette
différence la seule chose qui compte
c'est la manière dont les gens
s'occupent des autres mais
en tout cas je sais mon vrai fils est ce
que tu vois toujours sa mère e
non parce que
key
la droite a tué beaucoup de gens
qui l'a élevé je les ai élevés mais pas
très bien c'est à dire que je ne me suis
pas assez bien occupé que j'étais sans
doute un peu tyrannique avec lui je suis
de respirer quoi et
et voilà il faudrait lui demander à lui
si tu devais mourir là quelle serait la
seule chose que tu voudrais lui dire à
ce moment là je t'aime
frédéric l'émission n'est pas
complètement terminée j'ai un cadeau
pour toi
donc tu va me suivre oui d'accord
j'ai un cadeau pour toi robert venions
mais non mais non par bert de niro comme
ça r'commence pourtant ça fait quand
même un bon moment qu'on est ensemble du
mari je sais j'aurais dû faire des
progrès n'est pas ça en dés il était
l'ami de gérard depardieu dans 1900 il
s'est emparé de l'esprit de martin
scorsese et maintenant il vous met les
nerfs à vif
oui c'est lui le seul robert de niro
regarde
cela dit juste une chose c'est que tu as
eu du courage parce que robert de niro
comme murder alors lancé si pour une
fois je peux dire du mal de quelqu'un
terrible mais regarde les oiseaux
welcome in paris ce week homme une
double greffe de feu nourris produced by
hors production company when you are de
first acteurs du world wide to become so
close labeouf d'une peur de tout
des fois wittock bat hollywood vestris
like to know if tribeca produced somme
modique aux fans de rock director de
boxe thaï vers ithaque
[Musique]
roanne acteurs des actes au lieu de tuer
ou lève black ou doivent ils sont actifs
de produits mauvais président
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l équation
ah oui le hobbit interview with you to
remember de fast furious aux pistes
sophie roy face jobs fast milliards de
dollars de bijoux artisanat what will be
you lastras movistar rien
un ami un taxi marcel carné la brink's
figuration
on n'est pas tous les facteurs sociaux
martin scorsese
tout fan de l'auteur
cette jolie année mais il reste aux pics
françois truffaut thriller michael elia
kazan wait for mac
jean luc godard
quant au sommet des primes au sommet
jardi pardew
un doux rêveur de batagaï co laurent
baffie non l'univers de battre laurent
baffie les vernir life
ok would you prefer ou bien at il exposé
interview croisée aux pestes caste
santana une pipe aux hommes leur
globalité
ghost world series bénin caractère
thank you for good job
les ménages ou deux si l'interview est
ce que nous imaginer view préfère
staline et hitler série imaginée à tous
les fortes prises le space château je
préfère to be wild ronald reagan george
bush
gorbatchev
what is your video of happiness
on peut être amené à mener noir
il y avait une moto donc à marc au wild
side
gbagbo d'être certaine affection
pipolisation neuf sauf drugs
merci
oh
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu ce bleu